pour moi la ja pamela anderson nature
qui est la grande star aussi du
programme
mais c'est vrai que vincent moi c'était
là d'arcade du programme la rigolade
voilà je l'attendais toutes les semaines
et c'est vrai que voilà vincent ce que
tu es déçu je sais ce que je peux je
peut trahir un secret c'est vrai que tu
travaillais quatre heures par jour tu
dansais quatre fois par jour et je pense
que tu en avais plein le cul dit la
véraison me dit la vérité à tout autant
je veux dire si si si c'était facile ça
se saurait quatre heures par jour
si j'avais choisi sa première option
j'aurais sûrement le bac mais j'ai pas
choisi le choisi la danse était frais
dans tout l'arc la techno d'avoir des
comptes en est ressorti non pas qu'au
talent s'applique toujours quand tu fais
partie d'un truc que tu sors plus comme
un peu après sincèrement je ne sais pas
été tiré une balle dans les salles
d'histoire du combat est âpre et crise
aidant il faut quand même reconnaître
c'est le moins thomas ajouté la
prestation de vincent valade mutation de
vachon
la première est franchement quand tu as
un bras comme ça c'est vrai que tu as
envie de voir des démos danseurs mais
lui il a quelque chose qui la wii il
amenait un truc un peu du premier degré
mais bien que tu vas me manquer d'un
programme alors on va voir ta prestation
vincent chacha sur le titre amoureux de
ma femme de richard anthony la frère on
appris alors j'aime bien richard anthony
alors excusé par plus le mec a écrit ses
chansons et ont coupé les mêmes pour peu
qu'ils recommencent à pleine nature non
ça m'arrive aujourd'hui mais c'est toi
qui choisis semaine mémoriaux longtemps
est ce que c'est vrai qu'il est énervé
du choix de la chanson depuis la semaine
dernière vie mais bon à la vie mix sais
pas si tu vas qui m aurait que pour l'
écoute de la semaine parce que tu te
passe toute la semaine avait bien
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
il est sa part de prêtres mais après je
n'aime pas mais un peu quand même
ce que je veux te dire c'est même sur la
méchante plus clair pour mes oreilles
plus sympa mais sur le cha-cha-cha je
pense pas que j'aurais été plus en un
mois
baron